[Music]
on this friday night
the prime minister's chief of staff in
the hot seat
madam chair the prime minister yes or no
katie telford grilled on who
knew about the misconduct allegations
against canada's former top soldier and
when
i'll remind you what my role was in this
rising coveted cases and
rising unemployment new evidence the
third wave is infecting canada's job
market
locked up and languishing i cry every
day when i think about my husband the
canadian man stuck in a chinese prison
for 15 excruciating years
and a deep dive for answers the war
mystery that took
decades to solve
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening glad to be with
you
the prime minister's top advisor was
grilled today by opposition mps
about her knowledge of sexual misconduct
allegations
against canada's former top soldier
katie telford told a comments committee
she did not know the content of a
complaint against
general jonathan vance until global news
broke the story
her testimony follows days of demands by
conservatives to know
what she knew and when david aiken has
our top story tonight
and i was of course very concerned katie
telford spent
two hours friday in front of the house
of commons national defense committee
pressed for details about what she knew
in 2018
of a misconduct allegation against
former defense chief
general jonathan vance she was asked
repeatedly for example
why she decided not to tell the prime
minister about the matter
but she did not answer directly at the
time
what i was wanting to ensure was done to
protect the complainant
was that the proper next steps were
taken
and that's what i did immediately and
that's what i took seriously
and then there was no more information
to be had telford is trudeau's longest
serving and closest advisor
the pm's one and only chief of staff
there is no one in government with more
influence or power
than telford save for trudeau himself
and that's what made her testimony
central to the issue of accountability
and
it's why opposition mps found her
non-answers difficult to accept
not just a run-of-the-mill complaint
about sexual misconduct this is against
the person who is in charge of rooting
it out in the canadian military which is
what makes this different
from all the others you guys dropped the
ball as what's happened here
now let's you know this personal
misconduct issue that you didn't follow
up on
vance has denied all accusations of
inappropriate behavior
and telford said there was not enough
information in 2018
for the government to act my office and
the minister
were not given the substance or the
details of the allegation
we did not know what the complaint was
about tilford testified that it was not
until march this year
after global news first reported the
details of the allegations
against vance that she and trudeau
learned of the true nature
of those 2018 allegations and those news
reports this year
have spurred them to action because
you're right more needed to be done and
more needs to be done
the opposition today was focused on the
past who should be held accountable for
decisions taken and
not taken in the spring of 2018 and
that's an important issue but
the more important issue may be the
government's follow through
on the implementation of reforms reforms
that cannot come quick enough
for many women in the canadian armed
forces faro
and they'll be watching this closely
thank you david and a long-awaited bill
requiring new judges undergo further
training for sexual assault cases
has become law bill c3 received royal
assent last night in the senate
the legislation requires federally
appointed judges to commit to continued
education
on race gender and other social factors
that influence
bias in decisions
this legislation will help restore trust
in our criminal justice system
for survivors of sexual assault and for
all canadians
while making sure that everyone is
treated with respect
and dignity the private members bill was
introduced in 2017 by former interim
conservative leader
rana ambrose takovic 19 next and new
restrictions coming to multiple
provinces
after days of surging infections in nova
scotia
a record-breaking 227 new cases were
reported today
officials say they have no choice but to
impose tougher measures
they're pleading with people to comply
it feels out of control right now and we
will have a very tough may
that is the honest plain truth but what
what is also true is that if we stay
committed
we will start to emerge in june and can
look forward to a much brighter summer
starting tomorrow and for the rest of
may nova scotia's border will be closed
for all but essential reasons
businesses are being told to sell only
essential items
and schools will stay closed until at
least the end of may
manitoba is bringing in new measures
starting on sunday to try to slow a
surge in cases
and icu admissions in a rare
province-wide address held over the
dinner hour
the province's top doctor announced
several new measures including
the closure of gyms casinos museums and
libraries
indoor religious services will be banned
restaurants and bars won't have
in-person dining but
takeout will be allowed malls will
operate at 10
capacity the restrictions are going to
be in effect until may 30th
502 new cases were reported today that
is the highest daily count since last
november
the province says about 70 percent of
new cases are people
under 40. in winnipeg the test
positivity rate
11.3 percent
alberta still remains the hardest hit
province per capita
restaurant patios will be shut down as
of monday and the province is also
working on getting more albertans
vaccinated
and that now includes a cross-border
deal with montana
starting on monday alberta truck drivers
entering montana will be
offered a shot of the single dose
johnson johnson vaccine
the vaccinations will take place at a
rest stop about 2 000
truckers will be eligible
the third wave of the pandemic has hit
the canadian economy hard
statistics canada says the country shed
207
000 jobs last month the losses nearly
wiped out the 303 thousand jobs that
were added in march
the bulk of the job losses were in
hard-hit sectors that employ a lot of
young people
and as eric sorensen explains many of
those workers have been on a
constant seesaw trying to find work in a
pandemic
when the biggest province shuts down the
national economy takes a big hit
a third coveted wave has turned ontario
into a roller coaster economy
that keeps knocking the same people out
of work to like pay my bills
cover my debt that's dylan mawson when
he lost his job a year ago
he works at this toronto restaurant he
got back to work last summer and fall
when the distillery district reopened
but it all shut down again over the
winter and he lost his job again
i've been out a rope for a long time but
i'm still hanging on and i think that's
kind of
what most of us are probably doing out
there
like no restaurant is flourishing right
now so welcome
to the zigzag economy with the labor
market
dancing to the tune of the virus
the national unemployment rate rose 0.6
to 8.1 percent
last month not as high as a year ago
when the rate topped 13
percent but still unrelenting well above
the five to six percent range before the
pandemic
in the depths of a lockdown ontario lost
150 000 jobs last month
but covet 19 doesn't hit provinces
uniformly
ontario's unemployment rate jumped 1.5
percent in april
in bc which also imposed restrictions
the rate was also up
slightly meantime the jobless rate in
alberta and nova scotia actually fell
but those two provinces now face their
own covet-hit economies
nova scotia just imposed restrictions
after its biggest spike in covet cases
so far
and the service sector can expect to
take the brunt when the virus
is peaking and we have the closure of
the economy
you see those jobs in services in food
in retail disappearing very very quickly
still as the summer approaches analysts
predict the economy will rebound
vigorously
in part because a lot of money has been
saved and will be spent when places like
restaurants reopen
i know that i'm gonna be working again
eventually
i hope it's in the summer that is my
hope a hope shared among those hit by
the zig that they'll benefit from the
zag
in this up and down economy eric
sorensen global news
toronto there are concerns about the
supply of oil to much of canada
after michigan's governor ordered the
shutdown of a critical pipeline
by next week and bridge line five has
been bringing crude oil from alberta to
central canada since 1953
passing through michigan and under the
straits of mackinac
where two of the great lakes meet
michigan believes the aging pipeline is
an environmental disaster
waiting to happen as jackson proskow
reports a shutdown
could spark an economic crisis
what a gorgeous day we have today in the
waters near her northern michigan home
patty peak sees both beauty and concern
beneath these beautiful waters
is 23 million gallons of oil flowing
every day peak chairs the straits of
mackinac alliance
on environmental group fighting to shut
down what lies below
enbridge line five our great lakes are
at great risk
it's very hard to put a price on what
would happen if we have a
significant spill the pipeline from
alberta is fueling
concern in michigan because it's nearly
two decades beyond its designed life
span
it sits exposed on the lake bed at risk
from boat anchors and cables
one day more is one day too long
michigan's governor
agrees protecting the great lakes and
has ordered enbridge to stop using the
pipeline by may 12th
the calgary based company plans to defy
the order so you're confident that even
though it's
beyond the designed lifespan it's it's
still safe yes
and in fact it's not just me saying it's
the federal government saying it
in fact regulators in washington have
approved continued use of line five
enbridge is now in mediation and is
headed to court
arguing michigan doesn't have authority
to sever this critical link to canada
what we do know is that there will be a
lot of political statements
made but functionally
there should be no disruption to that
pipeline
disruption would be major jet fuel for
canada's busiest airport toronto pearson
comes from oil sent through line five
so does almost half of the gasoline
propane and diesel in ontario and quebec
the mayor of sarnia where the pipeline
meets refineries
says thousands of jobs hang in the
balance this is not just about a
pipeline to sarnia
this is about the relationship between
michigan and ontario the relationship
between the united states and canada
with the deadline looming the trudeau
government has pressed the biden white
house to intervene
if talks fail canada may invoke a
little-known pipeline treaty from the
1970s
long term enbridge has applied to move
the pipeline to a half a billion dollar
tunnel
deep under the straits a process that
would leave line five running as
is for years one more anchor strike
can change all of this back on the water
patty peak worries the lakes can't wait
jackson prosco global news washington
japan extends a state of emergency
coming up the race to keep the tokyo
olympics on track
as kovid 19 spreads plus the latest
province to prioritize
vaccinating pregnant women
new coveted 19 measures are casting more
doubt on the tokyo
olympics with just 11 weeks until the
games the japanese government extended
its state of emergency for
tokyo and three other areas after recent
restrictions failed to drive down cases
the government says it's hopeful it'll
get the situation under control
in time for the games a copin 19 vaccine
developed in china has been granted
emergency approval by the world health
organization
the sino farm vaccine is the first from
china and the sixth in the world to get
the green light from the who
it's promising news for the un-backed
kobach's initiative which aims to get
doses to countries in need sino farm has
reportedly offered substantial support
to that program the bc government has
joined ontario and quebec
in making pregnant women a priority in
getting the covid 19 vaccine
doctors have been sounding the alarm
about the growing number of expectant
mothers in the icus
with the virus research shows pregnant
women are at a high risk of developing
severe symptoms robin gill reports
danielle mcmanus is expecting her first
child and her first dose of the covid19
vaccine
the 35-year-old admits she had some
trepidation
and took the time to ask us many
questions with as many doctors before
making this decision
i feel strongly that it's the right
choice for myself and my family
is this your first cobra vaccination
today it is yes health canada has
approved the vaccine for pregnant women
and doctors are encouraging them
to get the shot at any time during their
pregnancies
there is a good safety data so far
with the vaccines in pregnancy and no
reason to believe that we will see
concerns
particularly related to pregnancy cobit
19 is now hitting people in their 30s
and 40s
hard the demographic many pregnant women
fall into
and the virus is putting their lives and
their babies
at risk when a person becomes pregnant
we know that they're at increased chance
of being admitted to hospital
as well as that increased chance of
being admitted to the icu
and while they're pregnant they're at
increased chance of delivering early
that's what worried megan gillie she
wears two hats
emergency room physician and new mom
gilly didn't hesitate
believing she's passing on a layer of
protection to baby henry
i was near tears that i was able to get
my vaccine
and to be able to do that before henry
was born was just
really exciting with the possibility of
antibodies
going from my body to his as well
there may be an added bonus of the
antibodies in breast milk but more
research needs to be done
after getting the jab danielle mcmanus
has a bounce in her step
and a weight lifted off her shoulders as
far as receiving a second shot no i have
no hesitancy at this time
one shot done another to go and there's
still that baby coming
in three months robin gill global news
vancouver
jailed in china you've heard of the two
michaels ahead we're going to introduce
you to another canadian prisoner
you're watching global national
[Music]
the arrests of canadians michael kovrig
and michael spavor bike china is largely
seen as retaliation
for the arrest of chinese telecom
executive hmong won joe in british
columbia in 2018.
the prime minister says it's obvious
that the two michaels were detained on
trumped-up national security charges
tonight jeff sample looks at china's
harsh tactics
and another canadian jailed there
camilla talandebaeva can barely look at
old
family photographs it's so difficult
memories of her four sons growing up
west of toronto
when i see them i'm very proud but
something is missing you know
camilla's husband hussein chalil was an
outspoken member of china's persecuted
uyghur minority twenty years ago the
couple was granted refugee
status and fled to canada becoming
canadian citizens
in 2006 they travelled on their canadian
passports to uzbekistan to visit family
but without warning chili was arrested
and extradited to
china accused of being a separatist and
a terrorist
and sentenced to life in prison i cry
every day
when i sing about this case when i think
about my husband
in 15 years she's had no contact with
chili
china hasn't even allowed canadian
officials to visit
i think hussein chili's case is
absolutely one of the most egregious
if not right now the most egregious
instance of
of long-term imprisonment of a canadian
citizen
on completely unjust grounds but he's
not alone
more than 100 canadians are currently
detained in china
including the two michaels their case
has garnered international attention
while chalil
has scarcely received a mention could
you share a little bit about your
engagement on the chiliol case
what canada's ambassador to china seemed
unaware last year that chalil was even
canadian
basically because he's a he's not
a canadian citizenship we are not
allowed to provide com we aren't
able to get access to him on our
consular services side yet
mr chiliol actually is a canadian
citizen jalil's canadian citizenship
is irrelevant to the chinese government
which doesn't recognize
dual nationality critics say canada also
treats dual nationals
differently and we just don't see their
cases rise to the top of the list
and it's impossible to deny that to a
certain degree there's an aspect of
racism
all those in favor the house of commons
recently concluded what chalil had been
saying for years
china's mistreatment of uyghurs amounts
to genocide
camilla hopes those growing calls for
accountability
might help to finally bring her husband
home jeff semple global news toronto
and tomorrow on the new reality jeff
speaks with an advocate who has spent
the last 30 years
fighting to free china's political
prisoners including canadians
that's saturday at seven right here on
global
mission for answers next where two
canadian soldiers
will finally be laid to rest
this is always an important week in the
netherlands
wednesday was a national holiday in that
country the annual remembrance of their
liberation
in 1945. of course canada played an
important role in ending occupation
by nazi germany mike armstrong reports
on the efforts to solve a mystery
for the families of two canadian airmen
who fought
to free the netherlands
it's not something she ever thought
she'd touch but it's part of fiona
williams family history
it's a piece of an aircraft bomber bk716
lost for seven decades with seven airmen
on board
that's william's uncle third from the
right they were almost home
and they got shot down just before they
hit england
the crew was part of a massive bombing
operation in march of 1943
more than 300 bombers were sent out to
hit berlin
33 were lost bk 716 disappeared without
a trace on its way
back to base in england well its
whereabouts are a mystery
no more
a dutch documentary crew followed the
recovery operation last fall
filming as a team carefully sifted
through the wreckage in fact
very carefully in addition to parts of
the aircraft
and personal items they did recover some
human remains
they haven't been tested yet but there
were two canadians on board
flight sergeant john macav of belleville
ontario
and william's uncle flying officer harry
farrington
of niagara falls we were very close
farrington's sister william's mother
still lives
in niagara falls he was wonderful he was
six foot two probably
he worked in the bank and the bank
manager tried so hard
to not get him to join up
the netherlands sent the family that
piece of the plane
they've been told all of the human
remains will be buried in a proper
ceremony
together as a crew that could happen
depending on the pandemic
as soon as this fall williams says
she'll be taking her mother
that it is something they will
absolutely not miss
mike armstrong global news
what a story sunday is mother's day a
day honoring the special women in our
lives
the pandemic means celebrations of
course are going to be different again
this year
but there's an eatery in oakville
ontario that's making sure tributes come
in and the community benefits
this is the nawal
is the italian word for grandmother
guests can put a photo on the wall and
for every picture the restaurant donates
a meal to those hardest hit by the
pandemic
that is global national for this friday
i'm farah nasser
i wish all you moms a very happy
mother's day i can't wait to hug mine
but soon until next time take care of
yourselves
and each other
you